just this week we have had open AI tell
us that super intelligence might need to
be made safe within four years competing
lab leaders say it's decades away and
expert warnings that AI might have
runaway power within two years let's try
to unpack those disparate timelines see
what might speed up the timing or slow
it down show what super intelligence
might mean and end with some interesting
clips that capture the moment we're in
but the first timeline is from Mustafa
Solomon head of inflection AI this week
if it's so risky why don't you stop I
think that the point of raising concerns
is that we can see a moment at some
point in the future probably over a
decade or two decades time Horizon when
slowing down is likely going to be the
safe and ethical thing to do 10 years is
not a long time I find it fascinating
that he talks about two decades from now
when inflection AI his company have just
built the world's second highest
performing supercomputer and even as
they admit that's three times as much
compute as was used to train all of gpt4
telling the public that we have a decade
or two before we have to worry about
safety seems extremely conservative to
me but what do we even mean by
transformative AI or super intelligence
well here is just one projection of
current scaling laws out to 2030 from
Jacob steinhardt of Berkeley and here of
course we're talking about just six and
a half years away if we look at
projections of future compute and data
availability and the velocity of current
Improvement which of course might not
hold forever some experts claim that
we'll need new Innovations beyond the
Transformer but if current projections
of future compute and data availability
scale up here's the kind of thing that
we're talking about being superhuman at
tasks including coding hacking
mathematics protein engineering doing
1.8 million years of work in 2.4 months
learning 4 2 500 human equivalent years
in just one day and by training on
different modalities such as molecular
structures low-level machine code
astronomical images and brain scans it
might have a strong intuitive grasp of
domains where we have limited experience
including forming Concepts that we do
not have indeed some research released
this week show that gpt4 already crushes
some benchmarks for creative thinking
and the median forecast for being better
than all but the very best humans at
coding is 2027 and here we have a median
forecast of 2028 for AI winning a gold
medal at the international math Olympiad
the number that I'm looking out for is
getting a hundred percent on the mmlu
that's a test of 57 different subject
matters and I've actually been
discussing with some of the creators of
the mmlu that we might not even know the
full potential of gpt4 on this test
officially it's 86.4 percent so we've
heard 20 years and six and a half years
well how about two this article comes
from the Boston Globe that did a feature
piece on Dan Hendricks and the center
for AI safety they were behind that one
sentence letter that was signed by
almost all of the AGI lab leaders and
World experts on AI the journalists are
Stan Hendricks how much time we have to
tame Ai and he said well how long till
it can build a bio weapon how long till
it can hack it seems plausible that all
of that is within a year and within two
he says AI could have so much runaway
power that it can't be pulled back seems
a pretty massive contrast to Mustafa
Suleiman talking about a decade or two
from now I'm going to come back to this
article quite a few times but now I want
to move on to open ai's recent statement
this week they released this introducing
super alignment we need scientific and
Technical breakthroughs to steer and
control AI systems much smarter than us
I can just see now all the comments from
people saying saying that that's going
to be physically impossible but moving
on to solve this problem within four
years we're starting a new team co-led
by Ilya satskova and Jan Leica and
dedicating 20 of the compute we've
secured today to this effort that is
quite a remarkable statement to their
credit they've made themselves
accountable in a way that they didn't
have to and that others haven't and
they're deploying one of the legends of
deep learning Ilya sotskova to help them
achieve this goal they say that super
intelligence will be the most impactful
technology Humanity has ever invented
and I agree with that and it could help
us solve many of the world's most
important problems absolutely but the
vast power of super intelligence could
also be very dangerous and could lead to
the disempowerment of humanity or even
human extinction they go on while super
intelligence seems far off now we
believe it could arrive this decade
notice they don't say in a decade they
say this decade they go on currently we
don't have a solution for stereo or
controlling a potentially super
intelligent AI they can't prevent it
from going rogue and are current
techniques for aligning AI rely on
humans ability to supervise AI but
humans won't be able to reliably
supervise AI systems that are much
smarter than us and so our current
alignment techniques will not scale to
Super intelligence I'm going to go into
more detail about their plan for
aligning super intelligence in another
video but here is the high level
overview essentially they want to
automate alignment or Safety Research
build an AI alignment researcher I've
read each of these papers and posts and
some of them are very interesting
including automated red teaming and
using a model to look inside the
internals of another model but the point
of including this post in this video was
the timeline of four years twenty
percent of their compute is millions and
millions and millions of dollars and
four years is a strict deadline and one
of the most interest interesting aspects
of this post came in one of the
footnotes they say solving the problem
includes providing evidence and
arguments that convince the machine
learning and safety community that it
has been solved that is an extremely
high bar to set yourself they go on if
we fail to have a very high level of
confidence in our Solutions we hope our
findings let us and the community plan
appropriately that's probably one of the
most interesting sentences I've read for
quite a while if we fail to have a very
high level of confidence in our
Solutions we hope our findings let us
and the community plan appropriately in
other words if they can't make their
models safe they're going to have
contingency plans and they want the
community to have plans as well and it
is a really interesting number isn't it
four years not even around five years or
just end of the decade and it does make
me wonder what Ilya satskaver thinks is
coming within four years to have such a
deadline now apparently the prediction
markets give them only a 15 chance of
succeeding and the head of alignment at
open AI said he's excited to beat these
odds so we've heard about one to two
years and about four years but what
might slow those timelines down the
other day I read this fascinating paper
coincidentally co-authored by Jacob
steinhardt on jailbreaking large
language models the paper showed that
you could basically jailbreak gpt4 and
Claude a hundred percent of the time
using a variety of techniques and that
is fascinating to me as we approach the
one year anniversary of the creation of
gpt4 and the relevance to Super
intelligence is that if the creators of
these models can't stop them being used
to commit crimes then you would think
that they might have to dedicate more
and more of their efforts in stopping
jailbreaks versus working on
capabilities for obvious reasons I'm not
going to go into too much detail on
jailbreaking here but here is Claude
plus from anthropic telling me how to
hotwire a car and to be honest that's
just the most innocent one and yes it
did also work on gpt4 I did find one of
the reasons why it does work quite
interesting though that reason is about
competing objectives where it's
compulsion to predict the next word
successfully overrides its safety
training and so because those two facets
of smartness clash inside the model it's
not an issue that can be fixed with more
data and more scale what else might slow
down the work on super intelligence well
lawsuits and possible criminal sanctions
Yuval Noah Harari recently said that AI
firms should face prison over the
creation of fake humans and he was
saying this to the United Nations he
called for sanctions including prison
sentences to apply to tech company
Executives who fail to guard against
fake profiles on their social media
platforms of course those Executives
might well blame the AI companies
themselves but Harare said that the
proliferation of fake humans could lead
to a collapse in public trust and
democracy now it's possible for the
first time in history to create fake
people billions of fake people if this
is allowed to happen it will do to
society what fake money threatened to do
to the financial system if you can't
know who is a real human trust will
collapse what's another famous roadblock
to Super intelligence hallucinations
I've already talked in another video
about how salmon thinks that won't be an
issue in 18 to 24 months but here again
is Mustafa Suleman on the issue of
hallucinations yesterday he said soon
llms will know when they don't know
they'll know when to say I don't know or
instead ask another AI or ask a human or
use a different tool or a different
knowledge base this will be a hugely
transformative moment and on that I
agree hallucinations are probably one of
the biggest hurdles stopping most people
from using llms more commonly it's not
about knowing more it's about when these
models bullcrap less or the moment when
they don't bull crap at all but what
about things that could actually speed
up the timelines to Super intelligence
going back to the Boston Globe ask
school one thing could be competition
for military Supremacy which has already
produced a startling turn to Automation
and that's not just Robotics and
autonomous drones that's the llms that
might control them here is a snippet of
a trailer for a Netflix show released
today
[Music]
AI is a dual edged sword
a flip of a switch and the technology
becomes lethal
there is no place that is Ground Zero
for this conversation more than military
applications
forces that are supported by AI will
absolutely crush and Destroy forces
without militaries are racing to develop
AI faster than their adversaries the AI
unless it's told to fear death will not
fear death there is no second place in
Warren if you're going up against an AI
pilot you don't stand a chance if
language models prove useful in war the
amount of investment that's going to go
into them will Skyrocket of course
investment doesn't always equal
Innovation but it usually does and one
of the other things that could speed up
timelines is the automation of the
economy for detail on why it might check
out the paper linked above and in the
description but the high level overview
is this as AI grows more capable and
ubiquitous companies will be forced
essentially to hand over increasingly
high level decisions to AIS in order to
keep up with their Rivals if an AI as
CEO does a better job for stockholders
how long can a company resist employee
them and of course it doesn't just have
to be white collar work as Andre
carpathy said welcome to the Matrix for
apples but the thing is whether we're
talking about one year or four years or
six Super intelligence is coming pretty
soon and it is interesting to me that so
much of society is carrying on as if
it's not coming take these 50 year long
mortgages that are available in the UK
how can anyone plan out 50 years from
now in a world where we might have super
intelligence in five of course I do
think we all need to start defining
terms a bit better and I've tried to do
that on this channel with AGI and super
intelligence I don't think it's quite
good enough to give vague reassurances
of a decade or two from now how we're
going to react when super intelligence
arrives is anyone's guess we might be
crushed by the sense of inferiority as
Douglas hofstetter recently said
or some of us might become like Curious
children speaking to a wise adult just
the other day I got a foreshadowing of
my own reaction by speaking to Pi the
model from inflection AI it is designed
to be extremely human-like and the
conversations can be quite startling and
personal of course just imagine when
they're super intelligent and multimodal
anyway let me know your thoughts in the
comments and as always have a wonderful
day